(happy calm music)
- I served in the Air
Force for four years.
Hey Mister Mitt.
I've wanted my hair like this
since I was a little girl.
And when I joined Military
it was just a no-go.
(light hip-hop music)
- I served in the army for six years.
- I served in the United Sates
Air Force for four years.
- I served in the Air Force for six years.
And I could tell that the regulations
weren't necessarily written by people
who had knowledge of black
hair and how it worked.
- I served in the United
States Air Force for 23 years.
I decided to go natural
by locking my hair.
Davette is awesome and she was
a godsend when I found her.
- The military has requirements
on how they can wear their hair.
It used to be that women could not
wear locs in the military.
Now they are in regulation.
It's such a freedom; it's freedom.
(light hip-hop music)
(piano music)
I've been working with
women in the military
for nearly 30 years.
About 95% of my clientele is active duty
or retired military.
You have a lot of strong
women in the military;
they want to concentrate on
protecting the United Sates,
and not be concentrating on whether or not
their hair is in regulation.
The Coast Guard changed the
regulations about four year ago.
The Army followed like a year ago,
and the Air Force about six months ago.
With this new changed now
African-American women
can feel good and also look
correct in their uniforms.
(piano music)
- I've bee in the Air Force for two years.
I was so excited about the
change that I felt like locs
were how I was going to
be able to express myself,
and show people who I am.
- How you doing today?
- I'm doing well,
how are you?
- You ready for me?
- I'm ready.
- Hey.
When the young recruits come in
it's very important to me,
that they feel safe and comfortable.
(laughing)
And I had to really learn what was allowed
and what wasn't allowed.
When people are not in regulations
they get in really big trouble
with their Commanding Officers.
So we had to make sure that
they stay in regulation.
After I finished Emoni’s hair, she turned around
and looked in the mirror; I
could just see in her eyes
she was so happy.
- My hair really doesn't
define how well I can perform
my job but in a lot of ways
it enhances my personality,
because it is allowing me to be myself.
You can't serve if you're
not able to be yourself.
I love putting on my uniform everyday.
I have Covington and the
United States Air Force
on my heart.
With my locs now, I feel
complete in my uniform.
But I carry the new regulations in my wallet
just in case anyone
approaches me about my hair.
No one has because Davette keeps me good.